foreign
[Music]
if you could go anywhere in the whole
world where would you go I always want
to be part of something bigger yes
Babylon is about a group of people who
find themselves in early Hollywood at a
time of extreme depravity and debauchery
and excess
[Applause]
it's the biggest thing I've ever tried
to do action
it was such an insane time it was just
wild like the Wild West
story follows multiple characters that
have an ambition to be part of something
bigger than themselves we've got to
innovate we've got to inspire
D Jack Conrad is the biggest film actor
at the top of his game and he's calling
a lot of the shots take two frames off
the tail and three more up ahead Manny
is our guide through the story these are
eyes and ears from an outsider's point
of view he's a dreamer someone that is
trying to find his way you can feel it
it's something bigger than life
Nelly is an aspiring actress she's like
a tornado hello
and she's not gonna let anyone stand in
her way I got here on my terms not
theirs
it's a uniquely different cinematic
experience and it's going to be truly
amazing
it shows a side of Hollywood beyond what
you could have imagined
I mean so much trouble
people are going to be really shocked to
see how crazy it was is this gonna be
what it's gonna be
it's really funny at times look at these
idiots
it's really sexy at times the film is so
big it's really an epic it's just
phenomenal
[Applause]
he like Grand
[Music]
what about you sorry if you could go
anywhere in the whole world where would
you go I always wanted to be part of
something bigger
love that answer something that lasts
that means something something more
important than life yes
[Music]
it's written in the stars I am a star
if I had money I would only spend it on
things that were fun you know not boring
things like taxes I'm just wanting for
everyone to party forever
[Applause]
when I first moved to LA Signs and all
the doors said no actors or dogs allowed
I changed that
and now y'all ready for something
different
you know we have to do we have to
redefine the form map those dreams and
print them into history look up and say
Eureka I'm not alone
all right
I'm in so much trouble Manny
we got to live now
you thought this town needed you
it's bigger than you
most magical place in the world
[Applause]
let's hang up who wants to see me fight
a snake
hell yeah
[Music]